well after that massive finale i think
there's one big character that we need
to talk about in the boys
that is victoria newman the
up-and-coming villain that burst onto
the scene in a mind-blowing way
throughout this video we're going to be
going through everything we know about
the character their comic book
counterpart
and our theories on what could be
happening in the future there will be
heavy spoilers here
so if you still haven't had a chance to
check out the finale yet then i highly
recommend that you make like
shockwave and head off make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
it without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka the spoiler man now let's get into
the breakdown
okay so victoria is actually a gender
swap of the character
victor k newman from the comics in the
original work
victor was actually the former ceo of
vaught and throughout the series he
watches the corporation manipulate the
political landscape
in order to get one of their own into
the white house vic is america's vice
president
and eventually he ascends to the hot
seat after vic kills the main man
himself
the power that he brings allows him to
pass laws that enable vote to receive
large contracts
and it opens the doors for supes to
infiltrate all aspects
of society vick even knocked out the
president during 9 11
so that vord could send supers out to
save a plane which
would hopefully boost their public image
however this actually led to them
crashing it into the brooklyn bridge
but vic kept the public's attention away
from this and thus there wasn't really
any retribution
vick is pretty much a complete [ __ ] and
at the time he was put in place as a
parody of george bush
who depending on who you voted for
you'll either love
or or also think is a [ __ ] what do you
mean you were five years old at the time
and couldn't vote
anyway because he's so simple-minded
victor or vic the veep as he's known to
many
is easy to manipulate and with one of
their own in the white house
vort gained more and more power however
as with most characters in the comics
victor comes to a sticky end and
homelander actually murders him
rips off his head and then plays about
with it like a basketball in the oval
office
yikes it's a massive moment that comes
at the end of the run
and it's the culmination of homelanders
soup uprising
now the show is clearly differing from
the comics in several ways
not only is vic now a woman but she's
incredibly savvy
and on the surface not easily led i
actually have a theory that she might be
able to also influence people mentally
and this could be how she's risen
through the ranks so quickly i'm basing
that on absolutely nothing though
but hopefully if my mind control powers
work you'll you'll also believe that
it's
it's true i'm sorry don't dislike the
video now we laid in the finale that
victoria can make people's heads explode
but her powers could potentially go far
beyond that and who knows what other
levels she can control it at
now what we know about victoria you know
there's very little
but clearly she's a parody of aoc a
congresswoman of new york who recently
rose through the ranks of politics
newman is seen as a sort of vunderkind
who on the surface seems to be against
all forms of vote and the superheroes
she bad mouths homelander in public and
holds rallies against him
and also helps to head up the u.s
judiciary committee
to start investigating the ins and outs
of compound b
victoria is also instrumental in getting
specific information across to the cia
and after she causes the death of rainer
she helps grace mallory to close in on
the corporation
towards the end of the season she even
coaches lamplighter and runs through his
testimony so that he can blow the doors
wide open
on what could really be going on at
bought after he ends up going out in a
blaze of glory
through help from billy butcher
vogelbaum agrees to testify
however at the hearing he and several
other key people are taken out by her
and
her crazy mind control powers now this
is pinned on stormfront
but as we learn in the finale of season
two it was vic
behind this the entire time there are
currently two theories going on
surrounding this
and we're just going to be discussing
them both now the first one is that vic
managed to access compound b herself
through either being a vo experiment or
by getting it through her political
power
the character does seem to really
dislike vort and if this is true then
she likely wants to take them down and
is using fire to fight fire against them
vic will likely ascend to the position
of the president at some point in the
series
and thus she'll be able to tackle them
head on it also makes sense why she
killed adona
as we learned that he had several files
on the company that she could take
and then used to blackmail them now the
other theory is that she's actually a
member of vort herself
and that they put her in place in order
to get compound b released to the public
which would allow the stock prices of
the corporation to rise
extensively it's extensively there were
exponentially
now this would be in line with the
comics as in that vic was of course a
company plant
and it would allow the corporation to
play both sides of the fence
all whilst pushing their products to the
public screencrush did a fantastic video
on this
that kind of goes over all the hints and
clues throughout the season that pointed
out she was a soup
so definitely check it out after this
now an interesting point that they did
pick up upon
is that vic actually has a daughter and
as we know from ryan
supes having children isn't that common
stormfront clearly told ryan that he was
the first ever naturally born soup
and as we know from the tagline of the
series heroes aren't born
they're made i do take this thing about
ryan being true
and thus the clues about when vic
received v are laced throughout this
season
at several points she mentions having a
daughter and because of this
we can take it that she was given v as
an adult rather than
being injected with it whilst in the
womb personally i think that cindy was
actually the one that developed the
power after being injected
and then vault managed to find a way to
transfer the head popping ability over
to her as an adult
and thus she started working for them
there's also potential that the
corporation actually have her child
hostage
and this is why she's willing to do
whatever she can to cover up their
crimes
now it could really go either way at
this point but i tend to lean more
towards the latter theory
as it just lines up a lot more with the
comics now as for her powers it has been
guessed that she has to maintain eye
contact when doing this
in order to be able to carry out the the
head popping thing that
it's sending everyone wild this summer
when homelander arrives at her rally
she doesn't take her eyes off him and
screencrush theorize that this is
because she must be looking directly at
her target
in order to pull it off this makes sense
as to why she was looking into a donor's
office
and as vault learned that the church had
blackmail material on the company
it seems like she had to go after him
directly in order to stop this from
getting into the wrong hands
at the end of the season she also hires
huey and thus it is likely that
she did this to get away to spy not only
on him but the boys themselves
now they do seem pretty disbanded by the
end of the season but should they come
back together at any point
vic will be able to keep a close eye on
their activities and report it to edgar
the boys were pretty much created to
keep an eye out on all of vogt's
activities
and i love how the roles have been
flipped here so that it's actually vote
keeping an eye on them
now things will likely come out into the
open and as we've seen from vic
there is a tell to her powers which is
that her eyes turn white
so i think it will get to the point
where people review the footage of the
hearing
and see that she was looking directly at
a colleague's head when it exploded
and that her eyes were also white when
this was occurring you don't really see
this in the footage itself
as i'm guessing that the show wanted to
stop easter egg hunters like myself from
uncovering it too early
but i think that this probably will be
revealed down the line
now that's victoria newman and
everything that we know about her so far
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
and theories so make sure you drop them
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video then make sure
you check out our full breakdown of the
finale which is going to be linked at
the end
we go over the entire episode so
definitely give it a watch if you want
more boys content after this
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of october so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been bald and
i'll see you next time take care
peace
you